während der deutsche kleinsparer sich
wie bolle über festgeldkonten mit bis zu
0,0 0 05 prozent zinsen freut geht
anderswo die luzie ab der große bitcoin
boom der börsenwert der krypto währung
liegt aktuell bei knapp einer billion
dollar neulich noch reines zucker geld
machen jetzt sogar firmen mit wie paypal
oder mastercard so aber hat ist so eine
krippe währung ganz einfach grundlage
ist die sogenannte blogs sind so
kryptographisch verkettete datenblöcke
mit transaktionsdaten oder noch simpler
erklärt und dann ist ganz zum schluss
eigentlich so genannten ort und die
sinnlos ist eine zufällige zahl die der
meiner ausprobieren muss und dann wenn
er diese zahl die dann entsteht also
time stamp der sie noch bei anderen
faktoren ich möchte mich einfach auf die
baar wichtigsten konzentrieren time
stamp die alte der hecht vom alten block
dann die michael roth von all den
transaktionen dem blog drinnen sind bloß
zum schluss 1 hinaus und wenn er dass
man in so genannten herrschen
algorithmus probiert dann kommt zum
schluss ein sogenannter erst aus
theologisch könnte ich den mittelteil
nochmal hören ja das problem ist um
ihnen bitcoins zu erklären müsste ich
selber verstehen
sicher ist nur eins wir reden hier von
virtuellem geld also für darüber duck
und sein geld speicher fest in jedem
fall eine umstellung bitcoin war eine
antwort auf die finanzkrise 2008 und als
wir damals reihenweise banken mit
steuergeld retten mussten war die frage
geht währung vielleicht auch ohne banken
erst mal gar nicht doof aber wie kommt
der kleine bitcoin auf die welt durch
das so genannte mining zu dürfen und
dieser schoss prozess ist eine ja eine
art rätsel eines scharia das lösen eines
rätsels wenn man dienstags erlöst dann
öffnet sich quasi ein schrank und in
diesem schrank liebten bitcoin ach so
ein bitcoin nicht im schrank
wenn ich das gewusst hätte ich idiot
guck dir ein ja die erwähnten rätsel
sind allerdings so komplex dass man
dafür enorme rechenpower braucht
lagerhallen voll zusammengeschaltete
computer und die nennt man dann bitcoins
thermen farmen die pro jahr mehr strom
verbrauchen als die niederlande vererben
wir unseren kindern also der einst nur
noch bitcoin ich glaube kaum
ich glaube kaum denn wir reden ja auch
von einer riesigen spekulationsblase ein
bitcoin ist seit dieser woche über
50.000 dollar wert im herbst 2010 waren
es acht cent
das heißt wer seine bitcoins damals
ausgegeben hat ist jetzt sehr traurig
erbaute deckelt vor etwa einem jahrzehnt
war die erste richtige bitcoin
transaktion im echten leben statt als
laszlo csanyi ext2 heiße leckere papa
john's pizzen für 10.000 die bitcoins
kaufte tänzerin bitcoins glückwunsch
zweischalige ami pizzen für eine halbe
milliarde dollar
ich hoffe die waren lecker hat dann noch
100 millionen trinkgeld gegeben
und wem verdanken wir den ganzen bitcoin
hype nicht zuletzt dem reichsten mann
der welt
elon musk für die einen ein gefährlicher
scheinriese für die anderen ein visionär
akku ein prophet der hat gerade für
anderthalb milliarden bitcoin gekauft
und damit den kurs durch die decke
gejagt ist ja kein einzelfall
als einmal in einer talkshow einen joint
geraucht hat fiel der kurs seiner marke
tesla während der sendung um sechs
prozent ganz ehrlich der vogel macht mir
angst
einerseits lässt einmal eben raketen zum
mars fliegen andererseits könnte er mit
einem einzigen bekifften tweet ganze
märkte durchs klo spülen viel zu viel
macht viel zu viel
außerdem wenn der e on schon so einen
einfluss hat kann sich nicht mal für
sympathische kleine firmen einsetzen
einfach mal twittern kauft eier vom
geflügelhof oberbexbach die besten eier
der eifel oder autohaus schwengel beck
ihr gebrauchtwagen profi im herzen von
herford oder die heute-show manchmal
lustige als das heute-journal irgend
sowas macht das doch eon die bitcoin
blase wie lange geht das noch gut meine
damen und herren ulrich von heesen unser
heute-show china investment experte
warnt ausdrücklich vor dem hype herzlich
willkommen zu
vorsicht falle nepper schlepper bitkom
liebe zuschauer reden wir über bitcoin
vorsicht ist geboten wer wie ich die
große inflation von 1923 mitgemacht hat
traut keinem börsen habe damals über
nacht alles verloren mit gerade mal
anfang 30 musste meine kinder an einen
wanderzirkus verkaufen andere geschichte
wo waren wir bitte hören sie mir auf mit
golden unseriöser quatsch das ist wie
ein kettenbrief du verdienst nur geld
wenn nach dir noch genug andere doofe
mitmachen
allein wenn man sieht wer für crypto
kohle werbung macht da leuchten alle
alarmglocken alte regel wenn sophia
thomalla mit macht und ein typ mit
russischem akzent
finger weg von dem produkt für die der
mit dem goldenen hammer geil geil
es ist tatsächlich so werbung für
kryptographie nur abgehalfterte promis
hier steht so im netz
oliver welke erzählt bei late night
berlin von seiner neuesten geheim
investition durch die hunderte von
menschen in deutschland reich werden ja
das habe ich auch schon mal gesehen das
ist aber vorlesen ganz wichtig ich habe
nie für bitcoin produkte geworben
entschuldigung es stand auch im internet
sie haben hunderte von menschen dass
geheimnisse ihres reichtums verraten und
mir nicht nach all den jahren
charakterlich das letzte ja ich war bei
klaas heufer-umlauf aber wir haben da
natürlich nicht über bitcoin geredet das
heißt sie wollten nicht mal klaas
heufer-umlauf ihr bitcoin geheimnis
verraten ich habe überhaupt kein bild
kein geheimnis ich habe nicht mal
bitcoins ja jetzt stehen sie doch zu
ihrem erfolg hier in einer anderen
werbung da zeigen sie stolz ihr angeber
haus und ihren vorlag
das ist auch fähig ich habe keine
ferraris also kann roten jedenfalls
diesen ganzen bitcoin werbung mit
irgendwelchen promis gottschalk til
schweiger ist alles fake goodbye
schweiger bin ich mir nicht sicher aber
sonst zeigt ist das jetzt angekommen
doch ich wollte die zuschauer halt
warnen bitkom ist total überbewertet und
es bleiben nur zwei fragen wann kommt
der große crash und man verraten sie mir
endlich hier bitcoin geheimnis welche
ich brauche das geld ich habe
spielschulden vorsicht von schlippe
bitkom bieler
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen aber da